Okay. So now at this point that we exit from the loop, which means that we
encounter the sentinel which is the, marks the end of the, of the sentence.
[CROSSTALK]. >> Are we guaranteed to exit?
>> Well-
>> You know, we'll, w'll have to fix the condition that we identified.
>> But assuming that we, we fixed it,
what happens if last character is not a sentinel?
>> Well, we tell the user, right,
that he should follow, that he should enter sentence, end it with the period.
>> That's right, the user are always right.
>> With their responsibility, right?
You have to take care of all the possibilities here.
>> Well, as you might recall on a keyboard and a computer, the period and
the comma are right next to each other, and
frequently people punch the wrong one.
It's called a slip in, in the cognitive world, and
they put a comma in and then this thing loops forever.
>> I was thinking, in fact, if there was an enda file without a,
without a sentinel at the end.
>> Even better.
>> Yeah, I guess then what we'll get, an exception exit, right, and
catching the exceptions, so.
>> Without printing anything out?
>> Well, you know, the, the user will figure out that they did wrong.
We gave them instructions.
I mean, I don't know.
If we want to account for
all the possible behaviors, sure, I mean, just you know, let's agree to do that.
>> Hey, listen son, this is Aviaonic software we're building here and
that means planes crash if we can't-
>> Sure. >> Characters in a sentence.
>> That's fine.
You've kind of been on my back the whole time, but that's fine.
I mean if, if you think we should account for the, for this thing.
We'll, we'll account for that.
Do you want to mark it down as as a problem?
>> We might send-
>> Crazy Bob, if you don't mind.
>> Maybe we need to send this guy back to the IT department.
>> I think we have read the point.
I think we have read the point.
Doctor Bug gets the point, right Doctor Bug?
>> Yeah. I, I get the point.
Yeah. There's no need to kind of reiterate every time like three or
four times but, anyways.
Okay so where were, was I